the 2016 presidential election is the
most expensive yet these candidates are
getting most of their money from super
PACs which are independent fundraising
committees or from personal riches but
not Hillary Clinton she's broken the
record for individual contributions
mostly in large donations Bernie Sanders
has raised most of his money from small
donations so what are small donations
good for well some credit Barack Obama's
wins with the flood of small donations
he received more than his opponents
small donations are a sign of populist
support but in 2012 Obama did embrace
super PACs which spent eighty million
dollars getting him reelected Sanders
says he doesn't want the support of
super PACs at all so can small donations
alone win the Oval Office